happy midweek football week in america
the football night in america family all
together here mine is chris sims we only
let out on weekends that's one of the
reasons chris doesn't join us on a
regular basis on these deals rodney tony
mike florio good good to see y'all not
good to get the news that we were
getting during the week uh after the nfl
went through tuesday mike with no
positive test uh wednesday obviously
that story changed in new england and in
tennessee again and with the raiders so
this obviously is something that's going
to continue to be part of the story and
mike i guess tony rodney let's start the
conversation what
what are we looking at here long term
with the nfl if we get to the reality
that teams are going to miss games and
not be able to make them up
well mike you know i'll start with
tennessee they've already had their bye
week move from week seven to week four
to accommodate last week's game being
postponed against the pittsburgh
steelers now with the titans unable to
get back into their facility on
wednesday as they prepare for the bills
to come to town that game just can't be
moved somewhere else we're already in a
position where the nfl has to
tack on a week 18 to the season move the
playoffs back a week something the nfl
has contemplated but didn't want to do
this early in the year but that's what
we're already looking at because this
outbreak continues in tennessee and now
we've got a potential outbreak in new
england two of the 32 teams so far and
look as the numbers go up across the
country and as guys continue to go home
every single night you're going to have
this ever-present possibility number one
of infection at home and then number two
outbreak whether it's in the facility on
the sideline in the plane on the bus or
on the field during games
yeah i don't think there's any question
about it you're just going to have to
stay flexible and there are going to be
outbreaks we are going to miss people in
certain games and we may have teams that
miss games so i think the nfl has to
devise some plan of attack that way that
it's not going to be fair it's not going
to be equal we're going to have to do
the best we can because this is
unprecedented
circumstances you know what coach and i
also i think the players are going to
have to be completely and totally
committed to isolating themselves
whether it's away from family you know
and and basically you know going to work
and coming home not going to the grocery
store getting some you know just just
being at home isolated my wife and my
daughter caught the virus and because my
daughter brought it home over to um to
him
and she's a nurse
and it's just like you know you give
somebody a simple hug and all of a
sudden it could pass
um it's just a scary thing and now you
look at the competitive imbalance you
look at what the patriots had to go
through without cam newton what they
possibly might have to go through
without stephon gilmore like you talk
about the fans mike being upset i mean a
lot of coaches i'm sure are upset losing
their star players
no doubt mike tariq and i talk every
week to uh notre dame football players
and their opponents and these young men
they're doing everything mike we talked
to ian book and sean crawford and they
say hey we go to the facility we come
home we study over zoom our tutors are
over zoom i don't go outside i don't go
anywhere
i'm committed to that and that that as
rodney says that's the attitude you're
going to have to take if you want to be
available for 16 weeks
and a lot of the guys are doing that you
know it's a reality that there are a lot
of players in the league who got through
all of training camp in the first three
weeks of the year and rodney i i think
you give us and one thanks for sharing
that and two hope everybody in your
family is is okay and continues to do
okay but by you sharing that it's just a
perfect example of
you can do everything right and yet the
people who come tangentially in contact
with you
may spread i was looking at the deal
that's going on in the white house and
we're not going to get political here
but just use this as constructive
in the debate prep for the president
last week were
hope hicks who tested positive kaylee
mcinadie the white house press secretary
chris christie all have tested positive
also in that room which sounds like it
was a relatively small area where rudy
giuliani ivanka trump jared kushner who
to this point have not tested positive
the tennessee titans played the
minnesota vikings on the football field
we're now nine days removed from that
the defensive tackle who tested positive
had 48 snaps interacted with the vikings
on the field the disease didn't pass to
anyone on the minnesota offensive line
or anybody on minnesota so
it's all illustrative of we just don't
know
there is no answer and we have to be
very careful mike florio this was a a
bit of a behind-the-scenes conversation
is it an investigation or is the nfl
trying to do just recon and find out
what's going on in these facilities
you have to be very careful when you
start blaming individuals or people for
being guilty quote unquote in this
starting of a spread sometimes it just
happens by accidental contact that they
didn't even know about
yeah but mike that's a very good point
and i've talked to multiple coaches who
believe that the league
is more inclined to place blame than
just say oh well it happened and the
league's attitude is if you follow our
protocols everything will be fine which
means if something isn't fine you must
not have followed our protocols and
there's some tension between the teams
in the league because there's this
belief that the league wants to be able
to say if anything goes sideways
it's not our fault it's not our
protocols it's your fault because you
didn't follow them properly
tony rodney you guys lived your lives in
locker room so how would you feel if
you're in this situation right now rods
where uh you were
kansas city and here came new england
after negative tests negative tests
everybody who took the field had just
been off a negative test and now you're
finding out that okay stefan gilmour's
tested positive and who knows who else
could have been possibly carry the virus
at that point when you played them how
do you how do you get your mind about
being being straight about playing next
week and the week after that
it's it's tough mike because um you just
don't know you could do everything and i
i thought i did everything perfectly
since march isolating wearing my mask at
home having eaten out at a restaurant
you know just only place i would go is
on the golf course and i would be the
only person on the golf course with the
mask on so it's it's tough and the fact
that a lot of these young kids these
young men they're so big and they're so
strong and they feel like they're so
healthy they feel like they're immune to
catching this virus a lot of them young
people they just don't take it serious
and trust me after seeing my wife and
seeing my daughter
go through this situation it's scary
because whether you lose your sense of
taste a smell
you know you sleep for eight hours but
you wake up and you felt like you only
had 20 minutes of sleep these are all
the different symptoms that you know
that your family members your loved ones
are feeling man it's scary so you think
i'm going to trust a 22 year old guy
that's going to come in the locker room
and trust that he's going to do the
right thing and you know he's out he's
he's got money in his pocket he's used
to being out and about and having
different people come through it would
be very scary for me in the locker room
coach
and i'll tell you my son justin is going
through it his high school here in tampa
their football team has gotten shut down
for the last two weeks
a student tested positive well they're
testing everybody else who's been in
contact with that student so far none of
the teammates none of his teammates have
tested positive but they can't play
they're in isolation so he's wondering
well does one of my teammates have it
have i been in contact with it and not
knowing is just as tough as well i
shouldn't say it's as tough as having it
but it's really impacted him as the not
knowing what is going on
that's fair hey let me ask you one quick
question about this then i'll move on to
some football
so
there's a week 18 possible mike you
mentioned that there's a week 19 which
would be pushing the super bowl back
apparently there's openings in tampa to
do that that's just the start of the
conversation the other reality is we may
not have everybody play 16 games
and go by winning percentage that's why
the commissioner set up this advisory
committee to deal with inequities that
normally wouldn't happen in the nfl tony
i'll start with you then rodney and mike
you can jump in
if we don't play 16 and somebody plays
16 somebody plays 14 we do it on winning
percentage are you okay with that
i think we're going to have to and i
think we're going to have to be okay
with it because the alternative is gonna
be tough do you have teams play tuesday
sunday uh that's not fair do you have
teams play without a third of their
starting roster that's not fair so we're
not gonna have an equal fair situation
and to me i think we're going to have to
get used to the the idea of winning
percentage is going to be the
determinant
i think i think for me
maybe what they should start considering
like you talked about mike shorten in
the season and maybe by four games maybe
you know possibility of just saying hey
you know four games we're not going to
play and obviously it can be
non-divisional games or non-conference
games however they want to set it up but
i i just think the more football you
play the more guys come into the
facility the more they're around each
other the more you're going to feel
comfortable just to kind of do what you
want to do and um and not really
you know follow all the protocols and
just get too comfortable so if you take
away four games which is
roughly a month
i think that could possibly help him out
a little bit florio
yeah you know i had two different
coaches point out late last week when
this first wave flashed and we had
titans then patriots and the scare with
the saints that ended up just being a
false positive play 12 games
bump things back if you need to regroup
use the bubble if that's what you have
to do but let's just do 12 games
everyone played 12 games one coach
suggested taking away the second pass
through the division so you play your
division rivals
once each and taking away one of the
non-conference games to even it out that
way but make sure i i think they have to
strive to make sure everybody plays the
same amount
those of us who follow it closely have
been wrestling with it long enough to
kind of accept the fact that well they
may have to go by winning percentage my
guess is once the average fan starts to
get a load of this they're going to be
extremely upset about the idea of
missing the playoffs because the team
that got in didn't have to play that one
extra game that they may have lost and
your team gets in instead
i'll just start these couple of things
real quick and then we'll move on uh and
again we're just speculating which is
dangerous and it's not prudent at times
in our business
maybe ensure that you play all your
division games and your division champs
go
and then winning percentage determines
the wild cards if you end up being able
to play all six division games because
it's the purest way to get those four
teams in and then the other three
determine by winning percentage
the second part is the bubble that
you've talked about mike florio
i think like we're watching in baseball
happen right now they're really going to
have to consider a bubble
if not a one or two sight bubble for the
post season
because it's going to be very difficult
to postpone postseason games if you get
a positive test here or there we're a
ways away from that we're going to learn
a lot more about how this happens
between now and then but i think those
are things to talk about uh rodney i'll
start with you there's a change in
houston the first coaching change of the
year uh and we're always cognizant of
the realities of what a coaching change
means it's families it's people it's a
real business but it is our job to talk
about the football part of it bill
o'brien won some divisions in houston
they did not get off to a good start
this year had the toughest schedule of
anybody in the nfl but at one four he's
out what do you see as that next step
that next chapter in houston
well let's first talk about bill o'brien
and i think you know the thing that
stood out to me when i first got with
coach he always talked about being a
head coach and the responsibility of
head coaches not just being able to
coach your football team but it's
dealing with all the other different
responsibilities that come along whether
it's picking hotels
which
airline you're going to fly just all the
different distractions and you put that
on top of bill o'brien trying to be a
general manager which i think he made
major mistakes of me who takes on
brandon cook's contract who trades for a
second rate um david johnson you know
those type of things and then you get
rid of de'andre hopkins he's the best
wide receiver national football league
so
you know houston has a great foundation
with deshawn watson but to me they just
get to a point where he wasn't
continuing to develop he was just
dropping back using athleticism and it
was really no rhyme or reason the type
of offense that they were running so
whoever they bring in as as the new
coach they need to come in and be able
to work with deshaun watson to get that
offense going they just have entirely
too much talent on that offense for it
to be so stagnant
and i'm not a big fan of
the head coach i'm not a big fan of
in-season changes i don't know what it
serves you it doesn't help your team
play better the one thing it may let you
do is get a head start on this process
and if the powers that be in houston are
looking and going to do a diligent
search then maybe that's a good reason
for it but other than that i just don't
like the idea of changing coaches i
don't think it helps your team at all in
mid-season
i'm just still confused by the whole
thing because
they tried to hire nick casario to be
the gm in june of 2019 that blew up in
their faces they decided to go forward
with no gm bill o'brien essentially
served as the gm in 2019 and after they
won the division
made it to the round of eight
led the chiefs 24 nothing in the
division around before it all fell apart
as we all know
then they decided to make him the
general manager that that validated
everything that he did they ratified
every decision he made they make him the
gm officially they get the schedule from
hell out of the gates against the chiefs
the ravens and then at the steelers they
lose to the vikings that's the only game
they lost they should have won and now
bill o'brien's performance as the gm in
four games gets bill o'brien the
multi-year head coach fired it's just
odd to me that it happens now
because it's it's not like ownership
wasn't
you know on board with everything that's
happened for the last year and a half
and now all of a sudden the guy's got to
go it just really does confuse me about
why it happened now
yeah it's an interesting job with
deshaun watson so many people think
desean watson has all that stark quality
we've seen it in performance and it'll
be very interesting to watch how the
names start to develop there is that a
place where eric b enemy whose name has
come up a lot because of his work with
patrick mahomes and his work with the
kansas city offense can he bring some of
that i i just the first time that i read
that bill o'brien was let go the first
thing i thought of was
what if new york
upheld the touchdown to will fuller
at the end of the game the replay on
sunday and they get the two-point
conversion they win in overtime and i
gave you three what-ifs but are you
telling me that you're gonna if they win
that game he's not getting fired so
you're telling me that you're making a
decision on your head coach after losing
to the three
best teams we think in the afc maybe
three of the four best teams don't
disrespect tennessee
and a call that was this close against
minnesota there obviously were other
reasons but i think if they win that
game he doesn't get fired sometimes
that's why i'm with you tony i don't
understand the in-season changes when
it's something not egregious
one question i have one question did you
guys see the way that defense played the
defense has been playing all year yep
that's it that's another part of it
they're just not playing hard and
physical they're not playing tough mike
and they've undergone a coordinator
change if the romeo cornell was still
there now he is the interim head coach
uh rodney i'll come to you let's start
on this game here this week let's give
uh quick thoughts on some of the things
you're looking at eagles and the
steelers the eagles surprised obviously
all of us since we all picked the 49ers
on the show
don't worry
we heard you philadelphia
we heard you loud and clear
i mean i i don't i don't think that last
pass fell incomplete before twitter
started lighting up with the eagles fans
for us right uh and and here are the
steelers we talked about rods just uh
hanging and waiting after last week what
are you gonna look for in this game
well i'm looking forward to just seeing
how that eagles offensive line deals
with tj white bud dupree and all those
blitz and zones and things that all the
different
different calls and just what they do on
a defensive side of the ball and coach
and i we talked about this during
football night in america that they put
a lot of pressure on you but there's a
lot of holes in that secondary guys take
a lot of chances they're very aggressive
they you know they try to create
turnovers so if carson wins and that's
what i'm looking for too can he is there
a level of consistency in in his play
will he be able to deal with the the
defensive line the pressure making the
right calls will doug peterson do a
better job of getting the ball out of
his hands quickly and also will they
continue to focal
focus on their best player which i think
is miles sanders offensively
yeah and i i have to give philadelphia a
lot of credit carson wentz played last
sunday night he played aggressive and he
didn't play reckless he made some things
happen but i don't think this week that
ben roethlisberger will throw two balls
right to them just like nick mullins did
i think ben roethlisberger is going to
play a lot more like cj beathard played
those last couple series
yeah yeah it's funny it reminded me of
the steelers quarterback who once threw
two balls right to cowboys defensive
back larry brown and super bowl starting
right i mean throw it right to him
but uh yeah ben roethlisberger better
than neil o'donnell and here's the
question about the steelers i don't know
how good they really are because they've
played three games and their opponents
are combined one in 11. the only team
that's won that they've beaten was the
broncos and all three of those games
could have gone either way even the
giants game where they were up 16 points
in the fourth quarter there was that
long drive in the third quarter and the
bud dude pre hitting daniel jones and
cameron hayward catching the ball in the
end zone that game could have gone
either way too so it's not like the
steelers have dominated lesser opponents
so i'm just curious to see what they're
going to do now against an eagles team
that's you know feeling pretty good
about themselves
and to your point the broncos won win
the one win out of that group that only
win came against the jets on thursday
night the jets are probably as bad as
any team in the league right now so i
love when you look at games and you're
like i don't know about this game but
all of a sudden it's very interesting
and that's indianapolis against
cleveland tony you have uh talked about
at length the lack of defense this year
in the national football league the one
place we've seen it for a month is
indianapolis what is it about the colts
defense that bears watching as one of
the better defensive units in the league
well i love matt eberflus he grew up in
the league in dallas under rod marinelli
they only play a couple of defenses they
play one front they play two or three
coverages they play hard there's nothing
fancy and he says i'm going to get good
players and i'm going to turn them loose
and let them be athletic and they hustle
to the ball and they try not to give up
big plays and so far it's been very
effective now same thing could be said
to them as we talked about the steelers
they haven't played
the aaron rodgers and the patrick
mahomes as yet so we'll we'll see what's
going to happen but i think they will be
sound against the run cleveland has
dominated people on the ground this year
i think it's going to be a fun game to
watch
coach you summed it up because i was
watching them this morning and they play
hard like you talked about they hustled
to the ball they got a bunch of guys
they don't they don't have a lot of big
name guys
you know that that's on that defense but
they play hard they hustle they hit and
i haven't seen a defense get five six
seven eight guys to the ball like these
guys get to the ball they play with a
lot of pride and you look at kenny moore
you look at xavier rhodes who was a cast
out from the minnesota vikings he's back
up there playing with confidence
physical and actually was the um i think
it was the nfc defensive player of the
year last um
the nf nfc defensive player of the week
last week
so um yeah they they're they're playing
good defense right now
you would appreciate this rodney
go ahead coach let me just interrupt you
mike rodney would appreciate this matt
eber flew grades loafs he got that from
rod marinelli and that is if if if you
change speed on the film you get a loaf
if you speed up that means you were not
running as fast as you could if you slow
down obviously before the the whistle
blew then you get a loaf but uh the
first time rod marinelli gave warren
sapp a loaf because he said i ran all
the way across the field and made the
tackle on robert smith 20 yards down the
field no but you weren't running as hard
as you can those first five yards you
were loafing that's the way matt eber
flew his coaches
i love it and xavier rhodes if he played
last year in minnesota the way he's
playing this year they wouldn't have cut
him they would have happily paid that
salary and kept him around he's been
great and that trade for deforest
buckner you know the colts knew how
screwy this draft was going to be how
uncertain it was going to be without the
full and complete opportunity to scout
players they were happy to give up the
first round pick to get to force buckner
and pay him and it's paid off and that
defense really is stepping up in a year
with no defense the culture this
throwback unit and it'll be interesting
to see if they can stop that cleveland
running game what fascinates me about
cleveland 307 rushing yards last week
even though nick chubb left with injury
after gaining 43.
yeah well that's the game plan
i'm sorry like my last point would be
that that would be the game plan for the
coast is to load up the box stop stop
the run game and force baker mayfield to
beat you you know i mean baker is he has
definitely have the benefit of a great
running attack they've got they're deep
in backs i mean they got obviously great
wide receivers but if you force baker
mayfield and he drops back knowing that
he can no longer run the football i
think that's the colts that i think
that's ultimately their defensive game
plan
i didn't want to interrupt you guys but
tony when you were talking about what
matt eberlus is doing defensively rodney
talked about what you saw watching the
colts defense this morning
it just made me think of
what i saw when i went back to watch a
little bit of the browns cowboys here
because i want to watch cleveland closer
and the odell beckham touchdown when
dallas is down 41 38 325 left the onside
kick they get the ball midfield if you
go back and watch that highlight
watch the dallas defenders they go to
the sideline and they check out travon
digs he just like stopped and odell
beckham ran past two guys who stopped
and that's the thing tony that as we
were watching here
we're seeing more
just simple mistakes look i never played
florio never played we can't be critical
at a certain level of what guys are
doing but when you see that kind of
stuff where there's a lack of finishing
a play or effort or simple stuff
that helps explain why we're getting so
many points in the league because some
of the basics are being left on the side
of the road they really are i was
watching that same game mike and i know
rod marinelli would be crying first of
all jumping offside four or five times
in the course of a game that is not
called for in his defense and then
secondly a guy runs
70 yards across the field and down the
sideline and no one touches him nobody
hustles to chase him all the way guys
stop
absolutely would not be tolerated and
coach you summed it up you said sunday
night fundamental football you give
yourself a chance at least you give
yourself a chance if you line up
properly if you have the right technique
and you come up and least try to make
the tackle you talk about dallas man
they're not even hustling mike like you
talked about they're not playing
physical they're getting completely
dominated i thought a guy
like tyrone crawford coming back from
injury i thought he was going to really
be a good player for him
i thought griffin i thought griffin was
going to come in and dominate and be a
good player for them these guys are
getting pushed around they they just
can't control the line of scrimmage
look the advantage for them is it's the
first quarter of the season they're one
and three and that is right up there a
half game behind philly in the division
so there's plenty of time to get it
right with dallas giants in dallas play
and that's the 425 national game for a
lot of folks on sunday it's the only
four giants of one and three cowboys and
just lost so much luster over the last
few years lastly guys our sunday night
game minnesota 1-3 seattle 4-0
tony as you have watched russell wilson
we talk we know his athletic ability we
know his leadership we know his deep
ball skills
what is it about this year that it all
seems to be coming together right from
the very start and magnifying what he's
doing on the football field
well i talked to their uh
quarterback coach david canales and he
said that in the off season everybody
came to an agreement that this team had
gone to super bowls they had been great
for years with a dominant defense a run
the ball philosophy and then russell
wilson making
magical plays to to pull games out for
them well pete carroll and everyone
brian schodenheimer the offensive
coordinator everybody said you know what
russell wilson's our best player now we
need to feature him we need to uh build
the offense build the team around him
and that's what they've done and i think
russell has felt that confidence and
he's playing outstanding football
yeah that's a mindset coach and their
mindset is you know what we're going to
put the ball in our best players hands
and we're going to score as many points
as possible you don't go out and get dk
metcalf you don't have the speed of
tyler lockett and the production of
david moore the third wide receiver
and and and not try to open up the
offense and russell he's doing a
wonderful job the thing that still
concerns me is that defense that defense
is giving up a bunch of yards people can
move the ball on that defense and you
can't expect russell to come out and
throw four or five touchdowns especially
against the better teams each week as we
get closer to the playoffs
and minnesota's a tough read you know
they were awful the first two weeks
they've rediscovered dalvin cook the
last two weeks gary kubiak's done a good
job of fixing the offense that opens
things up for kirk cousins justin
jefferson has come on strong after a
first two weeks that weren't great and
look mike zimmer's never beaten the
seahawks and it seems like every year
now they end up playing in seattle in
prime time
they get to go out there with no fans
and that's going to be a different
experience for the vikings than it's
been in the past and so you know you
know what's going to happen sunday night
we're all going to pick the seahawks
and then the vikings are going to win
and the vikings are going to let us hear
about it on their twitter page two
seconds after the game ends that's
what's going to happen
truth be told i i was this i was this
close to making the flip to the eagles
when i knew everybody
i just i just i just know i just know
that
even if you take the loss it saves the
grief for the entire team you know
sometimes you have to take a sack tony
and just protect the rest of the team
that may have been the moment to do that
you know i was hey
typically that's you
i know i couldn't hear you
i'm gonna give you guys a little heads
up as you're thinking about making your
pick for this week okay think about this
think about which team is going to be
able to rush the passer better okay
minnesota played green bay early in the
season aaron rodgers dropped back 44
times they didn't touch him one time
if they don't touch russell wilson it's
going to be ugly
flip it over okay kirk cousins he's got
some weaponry
and justin jefferson though they've got
guys who can torch seattle's secondary
seattle used to be a great pass rushing
team especially with the noise with no
noise and no rush if they don't get
pressure on kirk cousins it's going to
be a long night so my i'm thinking about
this and i'll be thinking about it until
sunday who is going to be able to arrest
the passer better
well maybe we can score 63-59
yeah i was going to say
maybe instead of a pick i'll just take
the over
can we do that
good chat involved you guys hey
everybody stay safe tony i'll see you in
south bend on saturday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports